you
yeah hello and welcome to the
stream another Sunday evening livestream
and I have a occasion to do that too
actually and they're both on the
left-hand side of the screen I'm going
to play if some 3+2 blitz games playing
here in a team battle let's go there
after go click a little bit yeah I'm
sorry that this doesn't look too well on
the screen but we'll get there so there
is a team battle in fact scheduled for
tonight and we have a leak system now
established on leech has more than one
leak actually and this is one leak that
is mostly comprised of German teams and
I'm playing there with my my hometown
club of Dean's Larkin it's not a huge
team but we have a couple of yeah
friends playing them and I'm not sure if
you're familiar with this format yeah we
have a couple of teams yes you see in
the in the tournament list and they
comprised of players and the top X
players do count so let's say in my case
if you look at to the Dean's Larkin team
this is a little bit badly formatted
because I never streamed the tournament
before but we have currently 13 people
in the list and the best seven will
account and yeah it's essentially
working like an arena tournament it's
just that the results for team add up
and in this case we what we need to do
is in this league this is the third
league of this um this league system
there is a Bundesliga the highest one
the first league at saying Germany the
second league and the third league
this is the third league and today we
are not in our best lineup so if we kind
of stay in the middle of the pack it
would be ok like roughly okay only the
first place goes to the league buff
which will be difficult
so we are currently one minute away I'm
not starting another game because like
it's just around the corner here the
start of this of this tournament like
now we have 58 seconds counting down the
other thing that I wanted to point out
which is important to me is what it's
also here in the screen on the left hand
side there is a tournament it's a
knockout tournament there chess common
is currently running and it's the I am
not GM speed challenge and that means a
couple of IMS are playing 16 of them in
a knockout tournament and it's a long
ish the match format so I'm going to
play a match in fact this is from from
from today on it's like tomorrow and
roughly this time 6:30 in the evening
against the tennis marcelina cash since
Khayyam so if you have time tomorrow
watch this match it's going to be can we
start now it's going to be a it's going
to be on the chess calm twitch channel
and will be commentated life bye yeah
bye grandmasters so you will get high
level or commentary for the matches and
those people will probably see much more
than I do so yeah it would be really
interesting I think to watch ok so here
we have a a closed Sicilian where white
is going for a slightly unusual move
order it's not moved to the bishop yet
and now he does put the knight on to
reform and I don't think I will record
that match locally for YouTube tomorrow
no I want to absolutely focus on playing
to be honest so I'd have not planned to
do any any streaming or anything like
that
there was a bit of a loose move because
Bishop g5 now is going to be awkward
ah yeah that was I have to focus it's
not so easy though this is a I mean to
580 something is not the end of the
world but it's a good player and I have
already blundered shoot okay I mean
white setup is absolutely harmless but
if you play if you play it like I did
you can neither six is just a bad move
of course it makes absolutely no sense
I'm threatening aged six now you know
things are fine absolutely thanks for
asking
gouge in school and hello to folks yeah
great have some regulars in the chat so
yeah here I'm doing not too badly even
though there was not the plant
everything okay now
probably just going to develop
still slightly uncomfortable this thing
I should probably take on age six that
play Queen f8 I will do that next
I guess our folks s-she moderated the
YouTube chat of the Magnus Invitational
probably this is must be pure hell the
twitch shed was already very hard to
stand like everybody and their their
uncle had something to complain and it
was really in in almost all of those
cases completely uncalled for or plain
spam rook c8 is just anticipating the
move d4 I'm playing a little bit too
quickly honestly it's three plus two but
in preparation for the match tomorrow
against I am Ashton's Khayyam cashed in
sky I'm sorry
I have played quite a bit of blitz and
bullet on chess calm to get to prepare
you simply have to get adjusted to the
site it's just very different the
playing experience on chess calm
compared to Lee chess and also compared
to just twenty four so it's important to
get this get a little bit of experience
with the platform so I'm hoping for this
I'm not sure if I'm better here or
anything but I have an interesting piece
configuration here the bishop on b3 and
the knight coming to see for his knight
on each who is an abysmal piece really
bad and what exactly is he doing about
the pawn on b2 I don't know what it is
the the met yes it's part of a bigger
event there are 16 international masters
taking part and it's a knockout format
so if I happen to win the match I'm
going to be seated into the next round
and there are some really strong players
involved for example if I should should
win if I am having to win it I will play
the winner of the match between
Elizabeth Bates and Eric Rosen you
probably know both players so I'm just
winning material him but my opponent
she's really strong she's got to a
rating of two thousand four hundred
eighty something so she out rates me and
classical time control in blitz I think
it's fairly fairly even it's what I
expect but we'll see what happens
I expect very strong preparation from
opponent tomorrow she she is married to
rattles laughs voice check the chief
second of former world champion Vishy
Anand and yeah probably probably
probably she will be a little bit get a
bit of support in preparation so let's
see what happens I won this game I was
good I think for the great feedback here
in the chat you watched so many of my
videos it sounds great
okay now I won the first game it was
good but let's see what happens now
so we're currently leading so you see
that there are seven players counting
[Music]
I'm not really sure that I am the
underdog in the match I would be the
underdog against her in in tournament
chess in classical time control chess
Mina slide one is like 50 or 60 rating
point difference but she's definitely
more active more of an active player but
I'm not sure what happens in blitz I
really have no clue she's fairly high
rated on chess calm in blitz and bullet
but you never really know what that
means
also because most of the online chess
ratings related to non increment blitz
or bullet and in in the chest comm event
we are playing increment all the time 3
+ 1 5 + 1 1 + 1 and this is an entirely
different animal if you ask me and
something that usually is quite quite
favorable for me not like anything
decisive but I I like increment she
white has f4 here this was a rook b8 was
a terrible move a really bad move Jesus
sorry I was bad
oh my goodness I'm completely lost I
just did not pay attention enough
I cannot take as bishop takes some wince
immediately so I have to kind of throw
the kitchen sink I don't know maybe it
is the other way around I'm just saying
that it's a reasonably well known fact
that she is married to or to avoid a
shag and so I wouldn't mind to be helped
by her world-class second in my match
preparation ok b5 is just like a bit of
a bit of a desperate call let's say I'm
totally lost
I mean it's not even it's not even a
fight or anything how awful well
absolutely terrible yeah what is
basically winning with whatever you
could consider to resign actually that
would be maybe proper match strategy or
tournament strategy match strategy is of
course the wrong term okay let's take
attack the beat hoop on and it's not
even that's an important thing this is
also increment to three plus two so I
cannot simply try to win on time flick
the guy from the faster player but even
though that it's not possible okay so
I'm going to take this it's of course
what why is that working so his culture
has got this check on d6
yeah I mean you could resign it could be
a good thing to do
yeah it should right okay so there was a
totally totally terrible game played
this like an absolute beginner I have to
focus more I was a terrible opening
result let's let's be a little bit more
focused I'm a bit down here and looking
at the board and at the chat and you
have to be I have to be a little bit
more focused on on the games yes this is
not just a single-player tournament by
the team event so a little bit of focus
is court form usually I don't stream
these events or do do any any sort of
video because I want to focus on playing
for the team and this is an important
thing we usually have a discord server
in place and and but we don't have this
today and the people who are usually on
the discord cannot play tonight so I'm
not missing anything so to say yeah and
I have forgotten my theory here in this
very cough I also have to absolutely
adjust to the time that is extremely
important I have played lots of non
increment three-minute in the last
couple of days and this is just so
different
okay let go Bishop to d7 look I don't
like this so much I don't like my
position here or still this one I'd have
to say Bishop c2 maybe
and then Bishop b3 yeah it's not it's
not good at all my position it's not
good let's attack this I don't know if
Bishop f7 was a good move I mean
absolutely not sure about it
on 95 I can actually not take it because
of Queen takes this is a bummer yes I
play in a team event yesterday as well
for my chest ball team okay if I take d5
Bishop takes I cannot do this hmm that's
a tricky position maybe I think also
take and play 95 this is also
interesting let's do that
93 is of course a very blunt threat yeah
not a very not very sophisticated but I
don't know if it's good
hello to master legend from shuffle in
the Augsburg they are also playing this
event I think so don't spy on me just
making a joke here of course so going
for the breakthrough
she takes rook takes so what's happening
yes he takes rook takes Queen takes
there's a check and I win the Queen
right now how do i if I take here remove
the defender of the g4 square
solving tactics the day can keep the
doctor away or something like that so I
don't really do tactics at the moment
but it's really helpful if you do check
and now how do we finish this thing if
five is hanging unfortunately Bishop aid
for Bishop c6 Mabius is an interesting
trial I don't see him anything yet if I
was hanging was checked so I cannot take
on g3 on the other hand it's just a
check right it's still threatened the
maid down does that work I just got to
check on e5 okay anyway let's let's play
I missed ninety-six actually I was
pretty bad miss I mean I don't think I
really blundered the game away but it
was absolutely not necessary to do that
I had 94 that was the absolutely most
basic thing to do but I think this wins
I don't see what he is going to do here
so Jake I'm going to be a piece up so
nothing too difficult I think to expect
yeah okay
it is increment so I will manage I'm a
little bit behind in the tournament I'm
honor you don't see that probably I'm
22nd at the moment the the loss on in
the third round is a bit of a problem or
the second round because you don't get
this streak going one thing I have one
request actually please don't send me
join the requests for the group because
it's only for my chess club so I'm going
to decline them it's not I'm not going
to it's not lament in any unfriendly way
it's just like it's just for our chess
club so very odd okay for black to play
with the night sitting here what's that
that's kind of cute I just play it like
a cat alone and black played I don't
know some kind of unconventional way
made in 22 in my game I didn't see you
made in 22
the engines nowadays can do remarkable
things but you don't see made in 22 to
often ok I'm out for Bishop b2 after see
if I'm going to play d5 yeah I'm curious
about the match tomorrow in particular
about the commentary team today there is
a match played between Tanisha Massa
Tonya such dev and levy Rossman and the
commentary team is really strong
it's comprised of Robert haves and we
did karate I'm not doing right here with
the pronunciation we did is rated 2730
or something is like world I'm not quite
sure number 20 or something like that so
a very strong player so if they have
this kind of a strong commentary team
tomorrow I'm going to be terribly
roasted for my play I guess yeah hello
vintage watch point greetings
so what I'm trying is to put the Queen o
to c3 and maybe build up on that long
diagonal after the somewhat dubious
opening black I think did quite well
he's not in terrible shape iam I mean
I'm happy with white with the bishop air
and so on but it's not like blackest
sorry in absolutely awful shape yes that
international master tournament from
just calm is basically one match today I
think there's one day where there are
two matches but it's basically happening
through them the the coming week
tomorrow is the third the third match
and it's usually starting a little bit
after the the Magnus tournament finishes
so Europe you probably will watch the
Magnus Invitational somewhat and right
after they are done that I am thing is
going on Queen takes there was d6 so
checking check check check okay let's
open this up
yeah so this international master event
is this a fun one I'm looking forward to
play and there are also many well-known
people are participating we have for
example Laurence Trent playing I mean
he's also doing currently the commentary
for the Magnus event and kind of I'm not
quite sure why somewhat controversial
he's playing and as Greg Hardy is
playing so many well-known I am so
playing as as I said already Eric Rosen
it is a bit paid so many well-known play
and also is charissa yep is playing very
promising junior player from the US I
think she's 15 or 16 and already had has
beaten the women world champion
Juvenal in in the in the Cannes cop
somewhat a couple of weeks ago so she's
a very promising young player yeah yeah
I'm going to meet him I think we should
be seven Queen a check and if he goes I
can go to evade but then Queen a8 so
this is also mate yeah so back to the
Chairman yeah hello I'm greeting sue
Carson and all other guys in the chat
sorry if I'm not as interactive I try to
but also have to get rollin we are
currently on the third place this is
good but this is all very very close
it seems that Latinos chest is not
playing I'm not yeah I did some practice
on chess calm but the thing is that I
want to I support my team this is kind
of a given that I'm playing this event
here on only chair so
this is what I do and I did practice of
baton chess calm in fact I was a little
bit surprised when they sent me the
seeding for that event that that I was
seeded solo I was seated and number 20
May 14 out of 16 and that didn't feel
all that correct to me and I checked why
because my ratings on chess comm were
completely terrible so I sat down for
two days played a couple of hours and
now my rating as a lot better so I'm now
rated similarly to them to the highest
seeded persons in the tournament so that
feels a little bit more realistic but of
course here I'm playing for my team and
not on chesil comments okay I have a
really good position here
I think Queen a forum comes to mind 497
check and Queen takes a 8 so I'm going
to he does not react to that
the question is Queen a 8 Queen a 8
nights seven and then he will take on b2
he will get a ton of pawns there hmm I'm
not sure okay
I'm also much better here it that could
be a wrong approach
of course but it's what it is
not going to spend ages e/m I'm playing
the number one seed in the tournament so
he's a little bit higher rated than I am
but I already won against him in the
first game and it seems that I have a
ton of history with them probably from
bullets yes I've played a bit of 1+1 and
ditches over the over the years so this
is not very much fun for black
I'm simply threatening to take on c6 and
demolish his pawn structure now
yeah Knight takes one what are we going
to do you know it is much better for
white done but it's not it's not clear
that it is winning it's not but I'm
going to do it okay he's not threatening
to take because Queen takes I will win
this back so I can go to a7 that is the
simplest one I think I'm going to do
that that is the simplest way to play
this is difficult to convert but it's of
course a very one-sided advantage
maybe it would be one what rugby one was
better I thought that is truly odd here
what he did so let's get the Queen
closer to this and probably yeah
probably the rook here okay do my dad
now I've got two extra points it's still
not so easy to win we have to say I have
no particular rating goal only chest
just want to play okay
d5 is what I'm going to go for here d5
and then
yeah this is the thing it's not clear
that the Queen trade winds it could win
but this is not totally certain
it's not clear that the Queen trade
winds
like to have this bishop on c4 or g4
maybe and then push the pawns yeah I
need f1 I need a form that's absolutely
certain just want to do this at the
right moment
how am i doing that the bishop has to go
to see for I guess yeah it's no other
way I guess so this one Bishop is on c4
in the Queen to e4 that is the ideal
configuration and then f4 f5 ideally so
now a form yeah this is looking good huh
it's got this check though I have to
prevent that Queen g6 checkmate so let's
let's get this under and get this rollin
this one
right he's got this check ideas Phil I'm
just going to repeat a little bit and
then see how I do this I had we had the
Queen's right I'm going to go for that
now I don't want you I don't want to
play this on forever okay doesn't go
Queen d5 it might be lost
also I'm playing a team battle yeah
taking this is clearly not going to work
only five I mean
that is a win I think f6 hmm maybe not
I'm sure f5 Wow
now the king cannot approach and go here
king e5 though threatening king of seven
now King of seven and that's it yeah
that was a bit of a longish way to
convert this position very long but it's
what it is
yeah I'm still a little bit stuck but at
least I won this and that gets me four
points now playing hide-and wouldn't the
dog from hell yeah so
stopping before for the moment yeah
thanks for the kind kind words about
tomorrow I hope it will help why not d5
white can play d5 that's not wrong okay
what is this
I can go gee 594 I wonder if that is
good I can also go here which is a
strategically desirable move let's do
this before there's always 94 that
doesn't really do much this a four move
was played to make the Queen side yeah
frozen in a way yeah frozen not like in
the in what is that Disney movie just
like you cannot move any any pawns there
okay so night c5 is going to be the move
yeah this is played and in a league yeah
it's a mostly German leak mostly with
the German teams is what I'm trying to
say that's a bit of a lazy move
admittedly
I don't want the guardian of hell this
is probably a good translation yes okay
interesting
now what this one may be it's a bit of a
controversial decision
I can also do that
what's going on here I have prepared a
little bit for the match tomorrow but I
will do most of that tomorrow
yeah I don't know that the Helen Hunt
might also refer to a comic book serious
sly that I think it's in German it's Tim
one copy yeah I think I'm not sure what
what the English worse version is is
that Tintin I think it could be right
from here Jay
I think it's something like that so I'm
a piece up but Helen Hunt is not
Adventures of Tintin yeah I also we are
Tintin I read all the comics when I was
a kid I was always good fun and the
Helen Hunt that was always what was
Captain Haddock when he was cursing yeah
he was always in German at least
referring to Helen Hunt
yeah this is some a comfortable position
because I have basically everything
under control
yes Archibald haddock its famous last
words yeah I've got everything under
control
yes head August the word it's for for
fish that's true
Knight f4 what's going on I can go here
right so now therefore I can simply take
but f2 is also a tax on the default rook
is hanging strong Knights there is
strong time to resign Holden hunter yes
okay so I'm not doing too badly I'm on
8th place but it's always a little bit
of a you have to get those streaks going
yeah I know strongest from a famous the
famous famous a movie it's very close to
have famous movie threatening Knight g5
which is duly ignored well that is
actually fun because I'm not winning
I'm just winning strategically I'm much
better strategically if it he takes I
take and I'm better I'm not winning yes
it was strong in the action in the movie
so we're doing okay with my team we have
77 points but it's all very very close
ally gets 10 points till 8 plates yeah
Punk
exactly and I'm playing shuttle to NASA
which exact German handle of course I
mean NASA is actually the German word
for nose but it is the translation into
English would probably something like
check your food will or something like
that like NASA can be in German it's of
course the nose but it can be said in
jest to someone you just want to kind of
put pull a leg something like that so C
3 I'm this is a position that I have
looked at the type of position in my d4
repertoire it is not much for white but
you can sometimes claim a small
advantage based on the on the pawn
structure we'll see if this is relevant
here maybe not blacks position seems
very solid he has the slightly worse
pawn structure but it doesn't feel all
that important well this is a bit
surprising whoa really
so he gives me quite a good good amount
of Tempe in this position like he worked
before even a five it's not it's not so
great not as great as I have thought but
it's a double attack actually if I go
here he cannot play rook c8 he has to do
it like that okay and now rook age force
also always possible so let's see it's a
bit of a pool a Queens gambit accepted
repertoire form black is something that
I had considered in the past that is
absolutely true and it might happen but
it's not very high on the list honestly
because the many many possible projects
and I think more likely there are other
things to happen okay now he 5s not a
move and he's a little bit confined
there on the on the back maybe he can
try to give yeah something like that
for Roxy to
this one and it's a good move
yeah and it was about plate public I
don't think I'm in danger but he
defended as well Roxy Chu is good
Brooks III probably as well I'm not
streaming the match against Aldina
questions Gaea tomorrow I really want to
focus on playing I know that John
Bartholomew did that with his match
against David purse but I want to focus
on the actual match on the other playing
I mean yeah well well played here by him
but black cannot do anything here yes I
have considered make it complicated
repertoire and something like that will
happen just not sure under what
circumstances but I want to do something
like that yeah make it complicated mix
it up make it whacky I don't know I have
a couple of ideas this is probably a
position where I should just offer a
draw on a slave it will seem
yeah I think I can offer draw him yeah I
don't know this idea with keep it
complicated is something or make it
complicated I'm thinking about a couple
of things it could be something that is
not as extensive as like the keep it
simple book where it's just like one
book with everything it could easily be
just a single repertoire let's say for
white how to beat the fringe or how to I
don't know how to play the Italian or
I'm just saying I haven't thought about
this but it could be something like that
so we got them yeah you can do that
we got specially cough and good a good
place so far by white
yeah I'm not so happy with this position
because my bishop only seven looks a
little bit odd
Queen a4 is awesome that's going to be
awkward
it's reddening Queen c6 in this position
neither five also a thing
94 is a move that is like it's nice not
doesn't work actually it does not work
yeah I am miss Plato's I really miss
played this opening quite a bit this is
not doing that much but it looks good
okay
inyoung it's not this is not the end of
the world this position it's not much
fun but rock g7 I only saw that now did
I blunder something I'm not sure yeah
maybe
efore Bishop f6 that was certainly a
thing I'm not really happy about my
position this is a good move ouch no no
no matter my opponent is not cheating
I'm just not playing well
this is a very safe way to play so safe
that I think it doesn't win for him I
mean he's a pawn up but how do you win
with whites probably you don't I'm
attacking f2 always so this is a bit of
a problem so going to go here this
should be six King c4 I'm even winning
that pawn even here winning in the pond
okay it's an absolutely no cheating him
he didn't I mean I don't want to say
played badly or anything this is not the
case but he didn't really do anything
special it's just like very normal ish
play for a human player now this is
really not that great
you know you see that I'm not in danger
of losing anymore and it's rather a
matter of trying to win but it's
probably not possible age five it's not
really doing and I should have given
gone 22 probably let's do that I should
do this
he's got the tempo them I completely f5
King bee three is a tempo i watch that
is not good that's a pain I had some
some slide winning chances I think and
of course this is you're not winning
it's kind of impossible you can just
stay on that diagonal forever yeah yeah
it was bad that was a bit bad I think I
had some chances at the end even to win
this position so close yeah we are
second very nice who's playing I'm but I
will Bush many German players clunk
quite clearly and that makes no sense
that's not D for happening I pre move
that you will often
only the first team the first placed
team does promote yes but I'd hire Bush
this is probably just a location
I mean I don't know I I meet some
cheaters and I report them but it is not
happening so often it's a matter of what
you think is frequent and so on it's
probably a matter of definition but I
think it's still not happening very
frequently for example in in those
events here and I've played this is the
fourth or fifth one that I played I have
played probably 25 to 35 games per event
that makes it 5 100 something games and
I had exactly I applied one cheater and
that was a second one that I found
suspicious but that was I reported him
but without being too sure and they said
it was not cheating and then it's fine
but it's really not happening so often
it is of course a problem I'm not
denying that at all but it's not like
it's happening I don't know every other
game ok so I'm going to entomb this
Bishop it probably won't help me as soon
looks a lot like a French defense no I
cannot beat the Cheetahs but I am
reasonably good at identifying them so I
feel if I feel it's if I let's say have
reported one person there might have
been more but not many more because you
know I mean if you're winning you can
win on time or something
like that yeah there is this ridiculous
video that I had I'm not an idiot
I know how people can't cheat I just
mean you you can see what's happening
and most don't do that they they just
don't do that I'm pretty well aware of
the methods
it's not like I'm naive it's just that
they are not that many people doing it
because they have a little bit of
information that you have of all the
cheating reports that get onto a website
like leeches 99 percent 99 out of 100
wrong they are not cheating in fact
ninety nine percent so honestly I mean
they it happens I've had it on video but
yeah I mean it's kind of pointless so
here I have a fairly can we please bend
this person I really just like I don't
want to talk about nonsense not ninety
percent are cheating this is just like a
troll trolling what you're doing here
and you want to irritate people that
makes no sense whatsoever it's just
wrong which is wrong I mean you can also
just just don't continue with what
you're saying I don't want to bend you
necessarily registers like just
ridiculous trolling and you make people
paranoid it's just not happening you
know why why this is nonsense because
90% of online chess players are
technical absolute absolute absolutely
incapable of doing that it makes
absolutely no sense what you're saying
okay so this is completely distracting
from the actual games so let's return
and I'm playing I mean the thing is you
know that you know that they're not
cheating all the time I win like 80
percent of my games if I played people
like that and I can it's a typical 21
whatever I win most of the games so
people are not cheating not all of them
there are some absolutely but it's not
that much it's really not that much okay
now let's have let's see what happening
here
we'll get funny enough a position that
looks a lot like a Spanish this is
something that I always find funny
starting with the Sicilian you get
something that looks a lot like a
Spanish and will
yes this is not about against that all
that much I have a huge experience with
this opening so this is a pretty good
Spanish also where black is having the
bishop here and some options my apology
who need what it's probably German
flavored honey is not it sounds German
but it has no particular meaning yeah I
do still play my old Spanish line that
completely closed down thing I do that I
do that still in blitz
mostly because I can play a million
moves and actually be ahead on the clock
this is something that is generally
useful of course in M blitz hello to get
here good to good to meet you
here on my channel Amina we met plenty
of course on various twitch channels
I still play pretty fast over the board
yes okay now I'm ready to play a five so
let's get rollin rollin rollin rollin I
play it simply the chigorin with black
that very closed line and quite
successfully I've only lost one game
with that a grandmaster against the
Grandmaster reasonably but I drew a ton
of GM's and
I've beaten some let's say yeah I am and
so on so my score is fantastic with that
opening so even though I don't think it
is that great that super close variation
is still it served me particularly well
really over the years ready for Queen g5
check this it's not a very subtle trap
but play the cozy oh I don't like that
line so much it's a tricky line but the
names of BOGO book lines I think they
are still quite playable I mean I
haven't updated much you know I haven't
looked at every single development there
over the years but I think in general on
those lines they are mostly of a
strategic nature so I feel it's probably
not very likely that there is a
refutation of most of the lines some of
them actually have become quite topical
for against against f3 for example yeah
there's a there's a Sicilian toilet
variation it's not particularly good
but I mean it's also not totally
terrible I would rather play the Timon
off instead of the Khan because against
the Khan you have to play really a lot
against the Hedgehog or you have to
let's say play a hedgehog and I'm not a
huge fan of this setup I cannot handle
it handle it so well very very odd
whites whites play setting up Queen g6
felt a bit strange that he had put the
night here now the night is hanging and
I have the chicks here Queen here
threatening here and queen g4 okay so
I'm slowly crawling up now second place
slow giraffe giraffe or whatever he has
more streaks yeah those four pointers
I played too many draws played too many
drawers and now this is the chance you
have placed slow slow gear of zeref I
don't know this is not the kind of word
that I can pronounce correctly so drink
some water
that is absolutely true Kaiserslautern
won the German football Bundesliga write
autobiography so you know all that
correctly there yes exactly my match
against Dena a question sky as part of
the GM I am NOT GM thing so never
slightly better position this this
position is mentioned in the green book
behind me either keep it simple T for
including all this with f4 so this is
one of the main lines we have widest a
little bit better because of the space
advantage I have not Castle this is kind
of useful that's a pretty that's an
interesting decision g5 maybe it's not
bad
mm-hmm so he wants to go to g6 very
interesting
I'm not in time to play h4 here because
it takes on f4 and n g4 is hanging
that's a bit annoying actually
that looks like a very well-played game
public
they look serious I'm just better
initially out of the opening but she
played this extremely well I wonder what
I missed them because this g5 was really
extremely problematic not sure that he
made the best out of his chances he um
I wonder if Rukh h1 is actually
interesting just is this Oh gauge edge
yeah maybe
I try to defend actively in this
position there are a couple of scenarios
that would be fairly let's say
non-critical yeah I don't feel again I
don't mind if he takes so much really
yeah very well played very well played
by him so okay now this one for a rook
b8 he cannot enter currently here yeah
I've got everything covered
Group B a does the idea if it was king D
7 I have rook f8 or like rook b8 King c7
and rook here if he has to go rook g6
here then I'm fine I think I should be
an okay at least so the check first or
how do we do this
I cannot go 92 because of the g2 maybe
this one tough game now this tournament
is just running for two hours and it's
still going on 40 something minutes no
I'm going to offer him a draw
you can try a five with black haridas's
kind of risky
he played very well out of the opening
I really had had nothing at all
tricky nine f-86 that was very strong
like g5 and Knight f-86 very strong
stuff okay um how what is the team
situation a bit too late to check I mean
playing prof chapeau it's a bit of a
strange move why do you go right into
this okay Wow okay this is the this kind
of thing always drives me nuts if people
like play stuff that looks completely
awful and somehow it's not losing
immediately I mean you can never know
that that it doesn't lose him merely
they just play it and it works for for
some whatever reason yeah okay so my
opponent was a very strong player right
slow easy rough or whatever you
pronounce it well Robbie F is a he's a
strong GM right okay so he played very
strong I mean it looked like a very
strong game bye bye black
okay so we're in some kind of pin c4 is
hanging so I'm going to cover it and
here Quinn b5 may be tough
okay now the night um I could move that
95 or something I'm not sure that taking
is good actually it doesn't look great
that's not g4 maybe yeah okay let's do
that
94 is not really that great
I thought that this doesn't work because
b7 is hanging but if I take cream b7
this Bishop takes you form ID C form mmm
okay I can also just take the Queen it's
the kind of chaotic position here knight
c6 he has 95 though that could be a move
97 I have no clue what's going on
this is hanging so should probably move
it yeah yeah it's very complicated
take B 7 C for hangs right I don't think
I could take B 7 very complicated game
and I'm losing a little and losing the
plot a little bit him
a little bit down clockwise okay
[Music]
interesting
not quite expected the way he handled
this
it's a very odd situation the night is
very odd very odd square
[Music]
yes is not my typical kind of porn
structure that is definitely true
he currently cannot attack the pants or
that well Wow he allows me to take this
it's kind of surprising
allowing this configuration seems risky
to me but I might be wrong of course
maybe rook c7 still playable it's a luck
luck Vox move yeah just about works just
about works crazy stuff this is also
funny a SS Czechia and then you can
basically permanently check me Nate's a
lockbox move of course that was not in
any way intended
I probably should make a draw or words
yeah the the lockbox means he kind of
stumbled into this
it just works without being planned
beforehand okay so it's there made or
something because I want to go here sink
does he chick made me I'm really good
with stuff like that running into mate
but I don't see it okay now um he's 647
let's go to 7 and now it doesn't even he
gets them root g8 how does he stop that
okay so I'm winning this I have no clue
it was a very strange game from start to
finish didn't get it
who so yeah I don't get the streak going
it's the thing but what is the standing
it's still closed down we are 17 points
away from the bad places down there
let's aim and we have enough players
scoring this is good and how much 30
minutes left so I should get some some
games in if possible okay so maybe this
is one of the yeah this is unfortunately
just good night f3 this is interestingly
enough not so terrible for like and
something that I recently checked and
it's kind of flavor looks a lot like a
standard d4 kind of position from the
from the BOGO actually I can unite if is
an interesting try and then the
immediate f5 this is not objectively
best probably but you can try that now
bring this night over night c5 not not
sure
maybe just go this go them night see
five is probably just not a very stable
move and I'd see five Quincy two before
stuff like that is coming in here this
is not very attractive but it's sturdy
maybe he's going for a c5 in this
position you know not very attractive
for this this thing
he maybe have f4 somewhere I'm going to
I'm preparing the rook trades down the a
file okay so what is he doing then c5 or
I mean c5 I can take and play Bishop to
b5 again I'm not really yeah I mean this
is not something where I think that
White has done anything particularly
wrong but it doesn't feel like the most
dangerous way to play an interesting
fact is that once he has played c5 he
has weakened d5 quite a bit and that can
become interesting for me but the thing
that has to be in place is I could have
taken only two Mamie and is the trade of
the bishops now because I can never take
the five as long as the bishop is on de
yeah this diagonal is critical but if
the bishops are traded I might be able
to take I don't use the the drawing
enough yeah you know you can do all
kinds of wacky stuff but it's not kind
of I don't have that internalized now
he's some wondering what to do this is
certainly possible okay so the rook is
attacked
there's also check iam a to my Queen
saying okay so rook could be aids you
know I guess would be aid
oh do we have something better don't see
it okay now here my rock now is not
hanging so I have this movie 'm then
it's got rook e1 it's a bit of a shame
Queen b3 also having a look at the pawn
here look teach who looks very loose but
maybe it's not an immediate problem
I could call would be six and he's got
to check
this check this only is just king of
tour that's enough really awkward
to be to is also in in the cards
attacking you three took me ages to see
that the Queen trade is nothing special
but it's what it is
f4
I'm completely okay if I can take and
play King e6 that's my idea now oh okay
I think I'm I thought I would just
basically pick up that pawn now okay so
he's got he's got c7 night here
I have completely forgotten that he's
got the end it was very unnecessary okay
yeah just a bunch of tricks going on
here
may I just add wrong there was some some
points there we're probably both results
were were possible yeah I don't get this
I don't get the streaks rolling this is
why I'm not competing for the tournament
win just dropping too many points so we
have to be careful with just 6 points
ahead of zone time it's close really
close you know I'm not happy I can
definitely score higher on my opponent
was irked that is a pretty odd thing to
do the problem here with the berserk
Inge is that you don't even get an
increment
so I have three minutes plus the
increment miss fork at the end maybe not
sure at which particular position but I
wouldn't rule it out in this kind of
time scramble this can definitely happen
Oh mind a little bit of back and forth
I've got much more time position is
about equal he does not get an increment
I can't take huh don't see why not
if they bezerk me I'm usually fairly I
mean they're like okay do do whatever do
your worst
let's say I mean I'm not some people
think you should counter berserk but I'm
not particularly good at that and I'm
usually just happy with playing
something normal and win in most cases
win
not so happy with the technical play
honestly what I did here was not ideal
but it's still very very good for Wyatt
so I've got a couple of extra pawns and
now even more stuff is hanging and I win
so I'm just just happy to play normally
and and win so Wow is that tough yeah
like 2 points guys we should win some
games what's going on here 18 minutes I
should do stuff as well but this is very
very narrow we could easily go down I
mean our our formation today is not so
good but still I have to be quick get
some points in
the problem here with the buzzer King is
simply that you don't get the increment
this is a real problem if you if you
would get it
I think the berserk would be very
powerful because if you have the one
second or two second increment the lower
base time is not so relevant I think it
would be quite interesting to be zerk
them but it is not possible you only get
the three minutes and no additional
increment okay who need him playing very
solidly but I'm definitely okay here
it's not exactly the kind of position
that you want if you
I don't think berserk gets half of the
increment I don't think so I mean I
could be wrong with it was always that
you don't get any increment maybe it was
changed what you're saying is kind of
sounds normal but I don't think it
happens that way
it's very difficult to make something
happen here he sees just yeah played
played super solid and now he does that
okay there is not super solid it's also
not terrible
Queen g3 is a good news she's playing
this quite well honest team remarkable I
just have to accept this pretty awful
position because the alternatives were
even worse very good by white I don't
really think I would fit very well
within the chess broth I have to somehow
somehow stand music which probably will
not happen awful awful position it's not
hopefully so easy for whites to win okay
he wants to go Queen edge for quite
obviously
so can some come back
pretty awful huh
this game was really bad made it draw
awful I really stumbled into a shootie
bad position that was really bad
now I was its fief it feel very scared
right should have simply continued and
win but so come on let's play quickly
and now I don't really play the French
defense anymore
offers me draw I don't know
not super enthusiastic about the
position what a draw is a bit or early
I have a bit of a hard time to
understand what he's doing here because
I mean he definitely is aiming for some
kind of counter-attacking
thing but it really looks a bit he's
given me so much space that I cannot
really believe that this is going to be
okay
like f-for next okay I can go Knight f5
as well
let's go ahead form and 95 okay now
he wants to go d5 I can I mean now I can
actually go back because he just
so I pushed him to h8 and it's like it's
it's pretty passive what yes but it
doesn't mean that it's bad you know he's
got f6 maybe I'm very much overextended
in this position a Bishop deform oh what
a shame I really hate to lose games like
that where they porn is just like
shuffling around and in hopes to win by
a self-destruction and this is what it
is he just basically waited until I hit
the self-destruct button pretty bad he
always just wanted to draw shuffling
around but okay it's what it is
threatening 95 it's not very subtle f5
is probably a good move
no okay
but surprised that you allowed that
Jake can take it but doesn't do much
no thanks a lot for gifting all the
subscriptions thanks a lot
that's really kind thank you yeah I
should probably resign this position the
scheme for the sake of the tournament
I'm always unsure about stuff like that
what is the good what a good strategy is
like tournament wise Bishop g6 now maybe
I mean he's kind of giving me some hope
here with his flight now I could win and
I think I'm winning I have 7 f7 is a bit
of a problem ok now my queen is attacked
so I can take on themselves that doesn't
do much Oh amazing that this actually is
working
f7 still somewhat problematic for him I
Scott that free and check unbelievable
the question is though how does he save
himself I'm threatening all kinds of
stuff
for example that that's made buddy
it's made Wow
I was not the most deserved win but it
was a win and all of the sudden we got
20 points that's nice we there was not
very home clean yeah that's
okay so shockwave
fianc and such okay this is just like
that's not going to count right
yeah I don't think this game is going to
count because there's only two minutes
left I'm not entirely certain about
about the rules honestly
yeah win quickly as always good this is
not doing that much honestly yeah I
think it will not count
offer draw is that a good strategy
offering a draw I wonder have no clue if
it is a good idea or not
point of us a drawer okay and it is a
point right I get a point I mean it
cannot be so terrible to get a point
okay anyway we have managed to not go
down that's good that's good
I mean that's okay I mean this way I got
a point into into the whole thing yeah I
think right I think so okay I play the
performance of two 588 so a little bit
above my rating which is kind of cabe
and I lost one game but I was a bit
lucky in some and all in all it was a
bit sketchy
if we check the whole thing um the
winning team was shot xuxa for new
Shireen we played them a lot they they
have a good blitz team anyway and this
time they even had a Dutch I am on top
that's super helpful of course if they
and the this person AMD Gong did not
play for them in the earlier matches in
the earlier tournaments so this isn't
this is new and therefore they are a
little bit stronger you meant they
managed to go up to the second league
that's really good congratulations
um right back
I wonder if blue boys that actually let
me check I think blue boys probably
bloody bamboo marquee and that's a
strong G m25 so he had this blue bomb
okay now we got the sound account
already an earlier other service and
slow G ruff is this for Robbie cough Chi
not good here with this
you have gained Evo hobby off I'm sorry
to five something so yeah he played a
very good game against me remember that
so right bar has two very strong gems
and a couple of other strong players we
can also check just for the moment I'd
like to check here on our end we have a
couple of people here in the points
seven in the points yeah very good job
and let me check here
yeah good team effort yeah and some
people in the points who were not in the
points in earlier tournament so really
good stuff again I'm very thankful for
the gift of the five subs by Pacific
victory it was really very kind of you
and I hope you enjoyed the stream I'm
not going to do much more if I'm on for
two hours now and I hope you enjoyed
this and before I leave though please
again make sure that the thanks for the
donation collodion that's very kind of
you
I did not see that in the in the middle
of everything yeah that was very nice
and I think there's also it she like who
this blue yeah and so I'm very very nice
thank you I'm I wanted to so on get to
the point that tomorrow is my bleach
men's match against am Alina cash in sky
um and it is starting at 6:30 p.m.
Central European Time so that mean that
makes it 30 minutes past noon I think in
the US East Coast I think if you look it
up
also on chance calm it will be easy to
determine the correct time for your
timezone it will be like two and a half
to three hours of blitz chess and I
think it should be quite enjoyable if
I'm playing a little bit better than
today maybe there is a chance we'll see
what happens I have to prepare well
tomorrow thanks a lot for watching the
stream and I'll be on
soonish I will do the odd stream not
like every single David on and off I
will thanks a lot and take care see you
tomorrow